hello good evening good afternoon good
morning wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel I have
literally just got off the phone with
one of my sources at MGM and I have some
very interesting Stargate news to share
with you so far it is the most
up-to-date information we have about the
state of Stargate and what Amazon are
actually doing during the strikes
so
we'll get into it we'll have a chat
we'll share some thought I'm trying to
find my intro [__]
let's get into it
[Music]
just ignore that it said syndex it's
Tuesday
but right this is a very last minute
video I literally literally got off the
phone with the source about 10 minutes
ago so we'll try and get through this
best we can
um we'll have a chat with you guys while
we're in it as well Wild Waters how are
you doing sir
um right so
please guys get to the comments as I'm
going through all this
um there's some good news and there's
some bad news here
so be prepared for that we've got some
really interesting practical information
about what's going on with uh dovu
um with practical planning that Amazon
have got which is really interesting
because I mean up until like six months
ago Amazon didn't have any sound stages
of their own
um by well within the next 12 months
they're planning to have a lot so we'll
talk about that in a minute they have a
new partner which is meaning they're
going to be able to get lots and lots of
sound stages very very quickly
um we have a few decisions been made we
have a few
um details or at least working plans
they've got Andrew Chandler how are you
doing
um we may have a budget for the movie or
at least an initial budget that they're
working on for development purposes
we think we have news on a director we
have news on Mark Ferguson Hawk host me
the guys that did the um expanse that
um they may still be involved we'll talk
about that a little bit
and there is some news I'm not happy
about but it's unclear about exactly
what that is at the moment but will
okay guys so we'll go into that Dave
Stewart just let us know we're going to
be a bloody SG musical
um
there is not going to be a Stargate
Musical that I'm aware of we've had the
200th episode of Stargate which had all
I think to be honest they crammed enough
quirkiness in that one to you know fill
we don't need to do it again so right
let's start off with this we'll start
off with a Hackman
Hackman Capital Partners right so the
Hackman Capital partners are a group
um of investment
people basically they have over the last
15 years built up 4.3 billion dollars
worth of media real estate all over the
world they currently own 120 sound
stages they're currently developing
another 90.
they are right now have already got six
sound stages for Amazon at call the
studios that's also where Amazon Studios
is based these buildings are actually
built especially for Amazon
what's wrong with the musical let's have
a musical why don't we have a let's have
a little bit of song star get it now
let's not do that
um
so yeah
um Amazon are planning by mid 2024 to
actually have something between 40 and
50 of their own sound stages now that's
going to come from a lot of development
work there's a little bit more
development work going on at Culver
Studios where they may add Studio space
there the Vancouver film studios is
having a large Expansion Project being
done at the moment
we're not having a musical
can I say put it on like you know
somewhere I don't know you know what's
what's the what do they have all the um
shows and things and musicals um in
Hollywood
it's the West End here in the UK If I
can't remember what it is in America but
anyway
um so that that basically means they are
basically times in by 10 the amount of
Studio space they have so there's a big
development going on at Culver there's a
big development going at Vancouver
studios in Ireland there's the Greystone
media campus which is having a 300
million dollar investment and actually
stargate's original home Bridge Studios
is also having a massive thank you that
would have done my head is also having a
massive Redevelopment project
um which is something like two billion
dollars or something no
500 million dollars but they're building
like
60 sound stages or something there
not going to be big vast time stages
though some of those can be quite small
sound stages they use for like voice
over work and stuff like that but
um
but the main point there is the
interesting bit is that currently Amazon
have apparently earmarked at least 15 of
these sound stages that they plan to
take over between now and summer next
year for MGM projects specifically for
MGM projects
now I told you a couple months ago I
heard a rumor that
um
yeah that Andrew that caused so much
controversy people either love or hate
that idea
I tried to try to tell people that if
they do an SGU movie which I've got a
video coming about in a couple of days
because I know a bit more about that now
I might be psychic
um if it's that or nothing I take an
animated movie all day
um
please don't do what stranger rules is
doing and be more of a metallist P3 so
I'll show yeah I think like the
Nostalgia and stuff Michael is what
people are going to be interested in and
that's that's really popular at the
moment
I think Hollywood have actually got
finally got the hint that we don't
particularly like remakes even though
I'm going to talk about remaking a bit
um and we don't particularly like
reboots and we prefer continuations and
we prefer a bit of nostalgia
that seems to have got through to them
saying that Babylon 5 hard reboot is
going to be on our screens next year if
if it all goes to plan so
so yeah
15 sound stages for MGM projects now we
know there's RoboCop that's one Sound
Stage we know this star game now I told
you a couple months ago that a different
Source have told me he genuinely
believes Stargate is going to go home
and it will be filmed in Canada he
thinks two of The Sound Stage is
probably at Vancouver film studios
though not the bridge Studios will be
specifically put to one side
for Stargate
um it'll be two or three quite large
Studios that will be just for Stargate
the idea being that TV shows movies
other things can be done together at the
same time they can share props actors
can just go between the two you know you
could have an actor in the movie and the
series and think and they literally just
got to cross the road do you know to do
it so it's efficient it's more it's more
cost effective and he generally believes
that's the plan now until now we didn't
know
for certain whether Amazon were actually
going to be renting and they will be
renting all of these Studio spaces some
of them have been built specifically for
Amazon but they're still being built by
the Hackman group so they will be owned
by the hakima group and rented to Amazon
the interesting thing there is though
after a bit of digging around the
Hackman group I have discovered that
Amazon are an investor in that group
that hackerman is a um it's a capital
investment company so there's lots of
investors
and obviously they've built up four and
a half billion worth of Assets in 15
years that requires significant income
um Amazon are quite a large investor in
that so even though the hackerman group
owned the studios Amazon kind of own a
bit of the hackerman group so we'll see
that
um precisely and indeed well any
opportunity to say indeed really
um I really watched Star Trek next
Generation here over and over again but
new track I don't watch it yeah exactly
and I think that's why Metallica's
Picard season three was so popular
because and I think it's actually why
lower decks even though not everyone
loves animation lower decks is massively
popular because it is TNG it reminds us
of that it's just better and I think
that's why this strange New World's
Crossover with actually lower decks has
been so perfectly done and actually has
seen a massive spike in Strange New
Orleans numbers and they've gone way up
the list for Paramount pluses things
this week
um I think they're moving
the episode and dropping it early as
well was very much done on purpose
um the numbers haven't been great for
strange new worlds so I think they very
much decided right we're gonna drop this
episode early straight after San Diego
Comic-Con people will talk about it boom
we get lots and lots of Interest
[Music]
having sound stages puts Prime in a
great position streaming was I think the
streaming walls are over
but they are pushing out really they
would like to overtake Netflix I think
that's that's true the stream Wars are
pretty much over though and they've got
to really
they've got a reign in their spending
but actually this investment from the
guy I've been talking to is saying that
this investment is part of actually
trying to spend a little less money
Amazon have been paying other people to
produce a lot of the stuff they've been
creating over the last 10 years
and they want to stop doing that they
want to start actually producing stuff
themselves
that's the whole point about having two
or three sound stages in Vancouver that
will be the Stargate sound stages that
they can do the movie we'll talk about
that in a minute and potentially then do
the TV series straight away and it's
more efficient and it'll actually cost
this guy reckons it can save them up to
anything up to 30 percent of overall
costs from what their current business
model sort of thing and that's a massive
saving when you're talking about a
project that's going to cost potentially
I mean if you're looking at a budget of
100 million
by doing it this way all of a sudden it
only costs 70. that is a huge saving
um the budgets they were looking at for
the 10 episodes
um even though there's been a couple of
rumors knocking around that Amazon were
talking about only a million dollars an
episode was nonsense it's just not true
it is does look like they were looking
at around five or six million dollars an
episode
if they can get that budget it is
equivalent to what starter expense of
like eight or nine million dollars an
episode so all of a sudden it's it's all
that money it's saving money and the
more money they save the more money they
can put on the screen and that's the
important thing
um maybe just have a quick so we need
sg1 I'll get infinity crossover oh my
God that would be so cool
I don't think I ever I must have watched
Stargate Infinity I do remember it I do
remember the car going through the gate
and stuff
so I must have watched it but I think
I've blocked it from my memory quite a
lot
I don't know most streaming services are
decreasing Amazon's actually uh Netflix
is doing okay they've actually seen a
bump but that's because of their um
uh they changed the password rules
didn't they see you can't have the
passwords so they're actually seen a
bump but everyone else is is struggling
um
if possible the problem with Prodigy is
I think they've just reverted back to
their old business model of Prodigy we
might even get a third season of Prodigy
yet
and the online petition just went about
thirty thousand
names which is more than the Strange New
World's petition ever had I just think
they put it on Paramount Plus in
Nickelodeon it didn't work they've
decided to go back to the original
business model of of porn out basically
to other subscribers so it's actually
going to go on I I think it's going to
go on Prime they've already they are
selling it now but I've heard in a
couple ones it's just going to go on
Prime in the second season will go on as
well
um and then if that does well
maybe Prime will order a third season I
hope they do because I think it's the
most Star Trek Star Trek thing I'm
telling I actually think if you're not
if you're a Star Trek fan and you
weren't watching Prodigy you've missed
out
some stupid episode but the finale was
fantastic
um
B5 is different reboot I think because
JMS is doing it himself it would be a
third party that did it ronmar you've
you're dead on there and
um it's true that JMS is doing the
Babylon 5 reboot this is this reboot is
being done by a completely different
team
we do have some updates on that as well
so
it looks like according to the source
I'm speaking to that the decision has
been made it is going to be a movie
at the moment the working budget the
production budget for that movie will be
something like 70 to 80 million dollars
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
will be the budget for the movie
the way it's been explained to me is
basically they come up with a figure
that they kind of like to spend and they
they tell the production the people
doing the development work so this will
be the director that apparently there is
one
um that's signed on at least in
principle they won't release that name
until it's signed on properly and they
actually announced it but and signed on
in principle
and the development team
they are given a rough estimate of what
they think the budget for the movie
would be they then go away and they do
the development work based on that rough
estimate
I'm told that that was estimate always
comes in low so the the end of budget
always ends up being a little bit higher
so I'm not terrified about 70 to 80
million dollars even though that is a
little bit low that's like that Batgirl
movie sort of budget
um so it's not it's not terrible but
it's on the lower end if you know what I
mean
um I think something more like a hundred
million dollars for the movie would give
me a little bit more confidence but the
end of the day we're gonna go movies
also this idea about the 1780 million
dollars but if they then do a TV series
they can spread some of those costs
around so say they need
um a new Stargate set they could build
that on the TV series budget so that it
doesn't go on the movie budget or they
build it on a movie budget and it goes
off the TV series budget if you make a
sense so they're very good at shifting
money around
a lot Studios actually like to do is
they like to just break even on these I
don't like these projects and not
actually make money on some of them
because then they don't pay tax
and then make money on the back end so
they're very good at sort of like moving
money around and moving the costs around
so that it all makes sense
um
I hear this comment a lot
if they woke it up they'll lose every
single subscriber and the real fan of
the franchise fact
if they push an agenda before everything
else then yes they will
um
Stargate was never really like Star Trek
is kind of woke I prefer saying awake
we've had this debate a few times but I
prefer saying awake it does talk about
you know
gender and sex and sexism and racism all
these and you know like the the problems
in society
um star game
never really did that so much they
touched on it in a few episodes they did
a few episodes you know had a moral but
generally speaking it was more bad guy
shoot the bad guy next episode you know
um it was nice so
yeah if
the development team that we think get
this coming and they are loyal to the
original series
that I don't think we're gonna have a
problem
um
is the original Babylon five worth
watching I never thought it came out
remembering Rich 100 yeah
um watch Babylon five it the third and
the start of the fourth season to the
best they the when you have the shadow
Wars and everything they're amazing the
first season isn't great if you've got
to play through that
um as soon as Sheridan comes into it
it's brilliant and the yeah the shadow
War bits some of the best sci-fi you'll
see it really like inspired Deep Space
Nine and
um
yeah you've you've got to see past that
it's nearly 30 years old and it didn't
have a massive budget then
um so
yeah you have to have to see through
that but it's classic classic sci-fi
right so where are we at so yeah we
think we've got this 17 million dollar
working budget
I am being told that development work is
still going on that there are still
conversations between Mark Ferguson
hawkosby they are still involved
um and
and the rest and and there is a
production team at Amazon that are sorry
at MGM that are still doing development
work
apparently currently there is no deal
with a second Studio
um a second Studio was involved at one
point and that was Warner Brothers but
they aren't now
except they still are but I'll leave
that for another video so that's a bit
of a teaser for you
but
um I was streaming on tubing now is it
it's not stream streaming anywhere here
Bible this is Babylon five I assume it's
not anywhere here but I think you can
get it through the Roku in the UK in
Europe so I think but I've got a DVD so
I don't really care
[Music]
um
I think we're still a transition where
the studios are trying to balance
sociological politics and good
storytelling but I'm confident they're
going to figure it all out sooner rather
than later Skyler I think you're right I
think
I don't really want to go to a massive
work conversation I want to get through
this but I think the studios had a
massive overreaction to things like the
metoo movement
I think it became very clear that the
Studios have been massively sexist and
racist for over a century and there was
a there was a massive correction they
got so scared of being accused of being
any IST that they just went the other
way
I do think though that writers
um have always put their politics into
TV shows and movies I just think maybe
the executives have were pushing it and
I think we're now seeing like a course
correction back again because
the woke
Brigade and the people that shout this a
lot have made themselves heard now I
don't think a lot of the stuff they
shout is fair but some of it is
some of it is damn right
agenda over story
you know and I'll always go back to the
Ghostbusters with boobs
um example they were basically they
started to do film and they got a load
of negative press saying about you can't
do this is a bunch of women are going to
do this
um and they just went can we and they
just I think they got so obsessed with
the negative
um uh press they were getting and the
people shouting that you can't do this
they forgot to do a good film
and they just kept the agenda just
overtook it
there's lots of examples of that
unfortunately where the studio seemed to
be having to put their hand up and go
we're not racist we're not racist we're
not sexist we're not sexist we we
support you the lgbtq plus community and
they don't mean to they can do it
through metaphor they can do it through
the story they don't need to make it so
bloody obvious
um
I do not want asthma to work to find my
Stargate yeah no I don't yeah
I'm a huge fan of the original Firefly
show I'd love to see them bring back the
cast Serenity great Edition well if you
know that you'll see them in my video
um about a week ago there are
conversations at Universal about
potentially doing straight to I think
it'll be is it peacock
anyway straight to whatever Network
thing I'm streaming service they own
movie Nathan filliam Alan tudik however
that's going to work
have had apparently very early initial
conversations
Nathan Fillion is planning to step away
from the rookie he will still be in it
but he's going to step away a lot he's
going to do a lot of the DC stuff and
then he will potentially do a universal
Warner Brothers partnership Firefly
boom
yeah I I it just was wasn't it and Star
Trek was a subtle about it the black and
white face thing it was a subtle it was
there was you know distinctly talking
about racism
and I think strange new worlds is
desperately just remaking Roddenberry
Star Trek at the moment
they're just remaking it so let's get
through the rest of this stuff
um
Harris if you're knocking around mate
you're welcome to jump in I'd love to
talk to you about this in a minute I
wanted to get through it first but if
you want to
um so
apparently again according to the source
Mark Ferguson Hawkins to be are still
involved they have still been doing some
development work apparently they have
created a Stargate Bible now the
Stargate Bible
um no that would actually the the
conversation is that the original
Creator would return
um and even though he's had some issues
um he would be back
um also the second guy
[Music]
um
whose name is escape me there's the two
isn't there but anyway apparently
they're both coming back
um Joss Whedon and the other fella whose
name's gone
um
so
right so they've done the Bible
the Bible is a agreed history
um
Harris is eating so you might be on with
us in a minute yes don't eat honestree
don't any thunderstorm
um
it is a history plan and so it's
basically an agreed
story of Stargate the past it is not
going to be a hundred percent Canon
Amazon have already made it clear to
development team that they are allowed
to change certain things and the Bible
is a document that basically agrees what
is solid and what is Canon and what can
be changed it may be sort of historical
in certain events
maybe certain episodes that are going to
say is still Canon and they're going to
be certain things so that they will be
allowed to alter if the storytellers
want to if they you know if they need to
Richard 14 Brad Wright is not involved
in any way he has had no contact with
MGM
um I don't know why they don't want to
but from what I've been told they didn't
want to from before the sale went
through they didn't they didn't like
Brad's script from before they'd bought
MGM they were they were saying that they
weren't happy with it apparently a lot
of the development work when the script
was going backwards and forwards with
MGM Brad Wright thought he was just
working with
um with MGM but actually Amazon were
secretly going to be the
um where the show went so they actually
approached MGM and said we would love a
Stargate show
MGM approached Brad started doing a
thing but at that point Amazon were
looking to buy MGM so they wanted to
keep it very much secret and because
Apple were actually the Front Runners to
buy MGM at that point so there's some
politics going on
but apparently as the script has gone
backwards or forwards Amazon kept
batting back and saying they didn't like
it
[Music]
um
thank you James Marshall for the
contribution they really helped the
channel and they'll always get read out
and I do go back to the twin brother not
wash but dry
I should have read it before I started
reading it yeah
perfect yeah I do love a dad joke I've
got to that age now which is all I do I
just tried to make my children go oh God
um right so they have the Bible and
they've also produced a Mrs Mark Fergus
is the primary lead on this they have
produced a history of Stargate and that
again this is then over the last six
months or so as bounce backwards and
forwards between MGM and Amazon
Executives they have agreed a Stargate
history and that will be his Target
history they can't mess about with
so
I like this though because
again
they're sort of agreeing these things
before they start
um I don't think they did that so much
with Star Trek I think they let Alex
kurtman just go nuts and he brought in a
lot from the JJ Abrams Star Treks and
sort of tried to make them Canon when
they're not
and that messed the uh particularly the
early Star Treks up the first two
seasons of Discovery were a complete
mess
and I genuinely think this is why they
then brought in people like
um Mike McMahon who does lower decks who
is very clearly a massive Star Trek nerd
and even Terry metallis and they they
started to fix it they started to get it
right and they started to untangle the
mess and put it back together again
that do seem to be
a very conscious thinking from Amazon
that they don't want to do that that
they want to have a very clear consensus
of what is Canon and what isn't
um and how to how to how to make that
work
how could you do a series Without a
Bible they do it all the time
unfortunately
um
it's because these things take a long
time
to put together
Star Trek the Next Generation did this
because it was such a big gap between
the original series and TNG that they
put this Bible together actually
Roddenberry was involved in it
um
you know it took a lot of work and this
is took this is another reason why we
haven't had an announcement already for
Stargate because this development work
has took
eight or nine months
it takes forever sgw yeah man I would
love them to release that wouldn't that
be a very cool thing to drop just before
the announcement
I've actually got again I've got a video
coming in in a couple of days
that I'm I'm a little nervous about
putting out because I'm only I'm not
massively confident with the source and
the information but it all makes sense I
think it's logical so I'm going to drop
it but it's very much a rumor but I
think there might be some quite big
plans for when they drop this that
they're going to drop it and announce
something almost immediately
um but I don't have cool it'd be to drop
it and then drop like
you know
um storyboarded stuff and like the Bible
you know I'm thinking like DMS remember
like did Star Trek the Next Generation
did a Enterprise
um manual and had all the detail about
the Enterprise D I love that geeked out
on that
yeah
the video the last couple of days we
will come back to this in a second I've
been in a video last couple of days
about the Ancients and trying to do a
storyline
figuring out where the Destiny was
launched
it's a problem because it was either 50
million years ago or a couple of hundred
thousand years ago or a million years
ago
um Joseph malozi says
that the city ships Atlantis Etc about
30 million years old
and Destiny is older than it so he
reckons it's a maybe about 50 million
years but somewhere in that 30 to 50
million years remembering 20 million
years is a long down time
um so
yeah it would be nice to get a little
bit of clarity on that and because there
were there were a few I I I say Brad
Wright Joseph Mosey Robert Cooper Etc
they didn't make many mistakes in
Stargate but they messed that one up
quite badly and it is confusing there's
a lot of things with the Ancients it's a
little bit confusing which is why I
wouldn't mind seeing an ancients prequel
series because it would allow us to
maybe clear up some of these things
um but I suppose look there's a massive
Gap
between
when the Ancients were knocking around
and us and you know they also existed
for like 50 million years
and one form or another obviously they
still exists now just as energy but so
there's going to be some confusion there
in timelines because it's just such a
vast information we haven't got much
archeology on them so it's going to be
difficult
um
I'd love to see the story of the
Atlantic alterans how did they get to
Earth and then create an alliance of the
four races yeah
yeah exactly in SGU they kept saying it
was less than a million years old
yeah and it was just a thing
secular Monk's got an interest to point
out how about if they did an animate and
sorry a a prequel movie
one of the big problems they've got with
whatever they do first and it looks like
we're going to get a movie first I did
my video a couple of days ago where I
was arguing we should get a serious fish
maybe you just have a mini series just
something I said like an SGU animated
movie because I think it's the only way
we'd get it
then a mini series that sort of like
ties up a lot of the questions we've got
from basically the last 15 years builds
a foundation that the movie can then
jump off because the movie's got an
awful lot of stuff it's got to explain
it's got 15 years to explain now it
could either just not not do it just
have an interesting story something
exciting something that
um any anybody anybody could go and
watch not just us skaters anybody could
go and watch it it's a two-hour advert
for them what will follow and then
they'll explain stuff later they could
do that
or
they could just to give us a movie first
you know give us a little mini series
first
because
getting the tone right for the movie
otherwise is quite difficult
and it's and it's good it's going to
satisfy the Gators it's going to satisfy
us
but it's got to be accessible to others
do a mini series let people watch that
let people catch up and what have you
and then do the movie seems to me the
obvious way to do it
um
so you could spin off on that
because again that only happened
a hundred thousand years ago according
to the timeline that The Wraith were
woken up and the war started ten
thousand years ago it was ten thousand
years ago so
um when you're talking about things like
launch in the destiny there's a that's
the nice thing I think with the Ancients
prequel is that you there's enough Gap
as well and we know we don't know enough
about the Ancients that whatever they do
they can do pretty much whatever they
want and unless they're completely
idiotic they won't peel over Cannon the
problem with Star Trek is they cut too
much detail in a lot of these things so
then when they do prequels
it steps on Canon and then it annoys
people like me that are a bit geeky
um
Stargate haven't really got that problem
they can they've been vague enough about
the Ancients they can do whatever they
want if anything we want a prequel
series which I've never said before ever
I hate prequels I freaking hate them
um but in this case I actually really
really want one because I want to know
more about it I want to know more about
what happened I want to know more about
how things like the Stargate and as well
one of the nice things is the Ancients
were technologically advanced so we're
not going to see one of these you know
the prequel Series where the
Technology's got to be older
because it's set 200 years before the
show we love
they've got more technology than
Stargate you know Universe even so
it I think it'd be exciting in all of
those respects
um
let me just have a look through
James Marshall
Stargate 65 alterans versus the
dinosaurs I haven't seen 65 yet
is it as bad as I imagine
let's have a vote in the thing just tell
me scale of you know one being bloody
awful 10 being amazing how good is 65 if
you've seen it because I think that
looks terrible I think that might
actually have killed that guy's career
so
um
sorry
I think you need to Define Amazon when
referring to its wishes yeah this is
Amazon at the end of the day
this is not MGM anymore MGM don't exist
and this is what people do have to
realize that Amazon have completely
absorbed MGM it's another reason why
this is taking so long
um
apparently if we believe Amazon the plan
wasn't to just absorb them but the plan
was to let MGM act as like um as a
satellite company they would make stuff
produced off Amazon would be the the the
the
people you know they'll be the customer
sort of thing
four three three
I'll wait for it to go on stream and
services if it's happening it'll be on
Netflix soon Paris you love everything
I'm not listening to you you love
everything
um
so
they then argued that actually was the
pandemic that forced them to absorb it
but I from what I was told a lot of
Amazon Executives they sort of went in
and had a look at MGM were doing English
the company was just such a mess
creatively as well as anything else and
just inefficient horribly inefficient
that they just went
nah forget it we'll just have the IP and
then just absorb them
a lot of people did keep their jobs
um a lot of people lost their jobs but
there was never that never made the
newspapers though because they never
actually sacked anyone
as people have left they've not rehired
anybody that's left MGM in the last 12
months they've just they just don't
replace them but also anybody who's on
short-term contracts which in the
entertainment industry is a lot
just had their contracts terminated so
they just they just ended and that
happened like instantly straight away
um I actually some of the sources I was
talking to just lost their jobs that's
one of the reasons why I was able to get
so many sources was because people were
so unhappy about what Amazon had done
they were willing to talk to somebody
like me
um and you know that has continued
basically the MGM is just it doesn't it
doesn't exist anymore as a company
everything has come now Under the
Umbrella of Amazon
um Amazon the heads of all the
Departments ahead of MGM and Amazon film
you know and I'm still talking about
Jennifer sulky is head of prime and MGM
Studios
um Courtney Valentini is head of film
and streaming for MGM and
um and uh Amazon
um the guy above that the guy above all
of them Mike something is head of him
you know so I think and MGM plus and
blah blah blah he said of all of these
things so there's just there's just no
you know there's just no thing
um there's no MGM anymore name a good
prequel
anybody there must be one
I liked Enterprise
I did like Enterprise my frustration
with Enterprise was they call the
enterprise
I think I'm gonna call the enterprise if
they'd have called that endeavor and it
had been a different ship because I just
got irritated because the Enterprise the
original Enterprise is the first to
Enterprise they call it the first
Enterprise repeatedly
um so that's irritated me so again it
was just irritated camera and actually
also the other thing is Enterprise if
we'd actually seen the Federation get
formed instead of that Bloody thingy war
that would have been great
Michelle's got it there yeah Rogue one
how do you like Prometheus
I didn't like Prometheus
right so why do they continue with the
MGM name
um this is a bit like when Disney bought
over Fox so there are tax reasons why
it's a good idea to keep MGM
you can when you've put a project in
it's it's produced by MGM but the um so
they're they're a financial reasons why
having it in and it's still technically
in some ways a separate company to
Amazon they it was a merger Amazon
didn't buy MGM that merged so that's a
technical thing
but one of the main reasons though is
Amazon Prime doesn't have a great
reputation and MGM is a century-old
studio the name carries weight the lion
roaring at the start carries weight also
technically the IP is still owned by MGM
which is still technically a separate
company so anything that is produced
that is an IP that's owned by MGM has to
be pastor of the MGM logo on it
even though it's only really
it's only like in principle it's not in
any sort of reality in reality it is 100
Amazon
yeah it's called this was an amazing
step on Canberra boom and level Sims
curtain yeah 100 and all they have to do
is not call the enterprise why is Star
Trek so obsessed with they must have the
enterprise we must do something with
Kirk we're on our third Kirk we must
have like it's a big universe Star Wars
is the same let's have another show
based on Tatooine no don't it's a big
universe I really hope Stargate doesn't
fall for this
right before we get anything there is
one piece of terrible news apparently
according to my source they have a
director
they have all this development work
that's been done
apparently
there is no decision on cast yet so a
lot of the Steven
um a lot of the sorry just sort of
Stephen King did Stephen King get
involved in what sorry I missed that pet
cemetery sequel will be good I think he
did didn't he
I think you did
um
pray was fantastic Dave I love that
movie I watched it again about a week
ago I love that film I can't wait for
prote it's gonna be amazing I can't
really can't wait
um I would say it's a prequel kind of
so yeah some prequels work
most now
um the other the main problem with the
prequel and I know I've said this before
but the main problem I have for the
prequel is you know where they end up
generally speaking right so we've got
the strange new rules prequel at the
moment we know where that's going
because we've seen the original series
we know bits and Bobs about the history
because we've got the original series
and things talk 20 blah blah so where is
the threat where is the danger
we know what happens
so
they've kind of insinuated that what's
happened to Pike which we know what
happened to Pike in Menagerie might not
happen
but it is going to happen unless they're
going to say this is another alternate
timeline
oh surprise stranger Wales is actually
the Kelvin timeline well I don't like
the events of it later but anyway
um you know it's just it's a nonsense so
um no that's why prequels but that's why
the Ancients prequel could work though
because it will be millions of years
before we don't know those stories we
don't know what happens we actually know
they die a lot so there is lots of
threat there that they can still do that
that a lot of the prequels we see they
can't do because they're too close and
they're they're too intertwined with
existing Canon so they can't do it it's
annoying
um they didn't really do well it was a
prequel but they tried to do Origins
but by that point MGM had no money they
spent no money on it
um our close friends Jenny stavan
actually did a lot of work on this
um and it had high ambitions
but it just didn't have the money and it
was a big idea that just didn't work
an ancients prequel would be completely
different particularly if Amazon
actually put some money in it Welcome to
our new member Safi 120 welcome aboard
sir thank you so much for supporting the
channel
um right so
one of the things I said though also one
of the things the source said though is
that apparently the director that's come
in has said
if he or basically can I explore the
possibility of a hard reboot
now he hasn't apparently said he wants
to do a hard reboot he's basically asked
Amazon if he wanted to if after all the
development work he couldn't get a grasp
of it and he couldn't figure out how to
do it or it didn't think it would work
could he explore the possibility of a
hard reboot and Amazon said yes
now
I don't quite know how to take that
because for me a hard reboot is
literally the worst thing that could
possibly happen
I don't think it will because horcos B
and Mark Fergus have been working on
this for a long time they have an idea
and they've done a lot of work on it
apparently there is according to this
Source again this is one of my more
regular sources
um he says there is a working script for
the movie that is and it's done
um so that's really interesting
apparently there is also an outline for
a series that would follow that's done
so they've got an idea how to do it the
directors obviously come into this
though completely fresh he's looking
over everything and he's I I hope this
is what it is anyway and he's sort of
gone
is is anything is any is there any
possibility you know is is everything on
the cards or am I locked into this and
Amazon have basically said work through
this
and you know but nothing's off the table
just yet now that may be just pandering
to the director sort of like you know
going okay they've got the man they want
or a woman could be a woman
um they've got the person they want as
the Director and the director has asked
this question and they've sort of said
look it's not it's not impossible we're
not going to take it off the table
but
I I think that's a massive problem
um
front so so it's just slightly off topic
but serious question if you're going to
race and beans and they were peaceful
but much more intelligent advancing us
and they have to thank you we're going
across the universe would you go have
you seen the movie Cocoon hell yeah I'd
go
well I wouldn't know it's got a wife or
kids but if I could take them
um I just think
Andrew I still think a hard reboot they
could build a better well thought out
universe but a software but will work
just as well there's
yeah guys come on drop a like on the on
the video it really does help us out
um am I going to be off for a bit longer
if you're quick because my throat's
going
um I'll probably push to to an hour
um but but yeah Dave I think Andrew has
a good point there that
there are problems
with just doing a continuation
the problems basically are
the SG by the end of sg1 we were the
dominant force in the universe we had
the all the Asgard weapons the Asgard
core the Asgard Shields we had the best
Fleet
um
the only other really threat to us at
the time is the um dilution Alliance but
they were basically use it as God to
have a goal technology
so we could take them out I mean our our
weapons will go and cut them bloody in
half sort of thing so
we were we are the the dominant species
I've always argued this as I want
Stargate not Star Trek when it comes
back so they have to figure out a way
to equal the playing field or we have to
have a bad guy in there that's gonna
sort of knock us back
this is why I actually argued that the
furlings could be or a section of the
feelings could be the villain and
they're basically ascended and they are
not really villains in case that they're
evil but they think we're too strong and
they think we're dominating or that
we're too powerful or whatever and they
basically come into
push straight sort of thing
um
they think they're the good guys but
obviously we have to they're they're
fighting us
so that is a problem
that the writers have to overcome
we have loads of Starships we have no
real threat in the Galaxy that we know
of we've taken care of all of it this is
one of the reasons why Brad Wright
decided to do SGU he needed to do
something had some genuine threat to it
because he basically got a point of we
were fighting Gods by the end of sg1
we've overtaken them
we've defeated them all so how do you
then
make um you know a story that's got a
genuine threat that's basically why in
Seasons nine and ten we have to actually
have the Ori we had to actually fight an
ascended being and because
everything else was just done
so yeah there are there are problems so
just for 10 minutes hello Harrison
how are you doing pretty well how about
yourself good good I'm very very well
sir so obviously you've been in the
comments you've listened to most of what
we're talking about does anything jump
out at you
uh first off no hard reboot but
um
I did a video ages ago and I did no hard
reboot loads of different languages I
might have to do that again that was
great uh
but you know I I guess what what are you
thinking about first like like the
budget wise or what I think the budget
and this apparently again you might know
a little bit more about this than me um
I don't know if you I said this seems to
be how high up executive stuff works is
that they've got this working budget but
it's only an initial
um estimate
that they then do the development work
off and then they sort of negotiate
again so apparently this 70 to 80
million dollars is that working budget
um that doesn't terrify me
no it's still a decent budget if you're
not paying one of the actors 20 million
dollars if you haven't got like you know
bloody Tom Cruise in it it's not a
terrible budget it's doable
for the filmmakers and the studio
so yeah I'm I'm thinking that might work
it just seems to be that this
interesting that we're saying decision
made on movie
disappointed but it looks like that's
done
so
yeah that's nice to have a little bit of
clarity on that even though obviously we
won't have a real Clarity until the I I
always just wonder that the day before
they could just go the day before they
announced you just go no excited let's
do a series I'm not completely changed
their minds but um
it looks like that's all the work is
going towards that
so
well I I like that you said that Hawk
Mark Fergus I always want to do it
backwards I always want to say that
first name and back name like Switcheroo
you know but Mark Fergus and hog off me
I love that they're still there uh
but yeah
they're economic filmmakers and I think
with the budget they had for the
expansion sci-fi think about what they
could do for yeah I mean long ago and
their budget was three to five million
dollars yeah and if they have a more
focused team that's been kind of a
well-oiled machine for a long time not
that they're going to be bringing back
like Brad or everybody else but like
they still have that Universe to kind of
dig in and kick around and
hmm
yeah yeah exactly
that is a good question for you then
right so Atlantis Wormhole Drive
um in the last episode was a big mistake
how can you explain the loss of this
technology
I know the answer to this but do you
know the answer to this oh you you we
tried to like push it off as something
else for some live stream I don't
remember what you said but
you told us that I just don't remember
what it was yeah it's already it was
destroyed oh okay they destroyed it
Amanda tappins Sam Carter basically
tells
um uh Shepherd that it's burned out and
they can't repair because they can't
even name half the Technologies so
that's one way they've already sorted it
out
um Jess Marshall has another
contribution thank you very much sir
ancients could be upset we are advancing
too fast and take it all away just to
get the gate and explore since they have
no Advanced civilizations that yeah that
was kind of my thinking maybe they're
thinking we're growing too fast
and
and that's why the bad guys then come in
and and give us a smack another new
member thank you Richard slack for
becoming a YouTube member
you supporting the channel thank you
very very much
um does that make sense to you though
what the Ancients uh kind of
taking things away just as much yeah
that makes sense
there are
you I've lost you a second but I think
there's either two possibilities if
we've either got to get a villain that
is just like super powerful or they just
do monster of the week stuff and they
just do problems you know a team goes
through gate has a problem
comes back you know we just have they
don't necessarily need to have an Uber
evil villain immediately no uh I
I honestly kind of like them to go the
Mandalorian route where it is kind of
monster of the week kind of like oh what
Adventure are we gonna get ourselves
going on for like the first season and a
half and then you kind of have those
inklings of a larger story that are like
kind of being teased for a little bit
and then we finally get that hopefully
their season three is a little more well
fueled than uh Nando season three was
but I I've got hope you know especially
if they plan it out a little better
from the get-go it'd be nice
this just focuses down very quickly are
you a local rich
um
find me on Facebook and message and say
hello if you are
um I've told people I live in Telford so
I think that's in the West Midlands in
England I think I don't think I'm in any
danger of anybody like any fans stalking
me or anything but
um
when I went to America none of you
turned up
sorry but I don't know 51 of my audience
is in America not one of you turned up
um but anyway my wife saw her cousin
right we knew she was in New York and
she said I'll um we'll we'll try to get
together
but then we never we never sort of
arranged it and then all of a sudden we
heard Attica
she was just walking down the street we
just bumped into each other in New York
so your wife had a better welcoming
party than you did exactly
she knew not one of you blocked turned
anyway please don't ever if you do ever
see me in public please don't leave a
sailor I would I would die
give him a jump scare from the back ah
of course we have tofu
come here but it's Ash it's all rich
um yeah so what else we got what else we
got what else we got I like that
do you think it's a problem hard reboot
though do you think it's actually a
problem that the director at least uh
asked the question
who asked the question so apparently
who's the director that asked a question
about the hard reboot so they've
apparently there is a director they have
a verbal agreement with so no contract
has been signed according to the source
okay but there's been a verbal agreement
and the director is is having
conversations about the development work
and apparently the conversation
basically went
if we can't I don't know if there must
be some problems or something with it
with certain aspects of the story and if
you can't figure it out
can we just do a hard reboot is that or
is that off the table
and Amazon's question there is no but we
would rather that you didn't sort of
thing
I mean I
I see the appeal but
there's also 10 times the appeal to
continue it you know yeah
that's what the fans want we don't want
a hard reboot
when I've asked the or when I've asked
you guys before like 90 something
percent of you say no hard reboot
um it's like there are still people that
recognize yeah okay it could it could be
better in some ways
but generally speaking
yeah
yeah there are Stargate novels they
could look at yeah 100 we've got a lot
of beta Cannon to look at
again there were things like that we
could do they don't have to do a big
Sci-Fi show they could do something like
that they could do I would love to see a
a Ronin movie you know like the the
runners or something like that
um not even super expensive just give
them a MOA like 70 I mean that's still
pretty expensive but give them like 50
60 70 million dollars and just let them
have like a small budget film he loves
indie films it'd be perfect it'd be
perfect
again and producer credit and you know
things like that sort of thing as well
and he might go for that
um
I I would I would just adore that
um and but there are it's a big universe
we don't there are ways around this
problem with the hard reboot idea and I
would say the movie is I I I'd actually
argue the movie can't be a big sci-fi
that sort of thing it can't be all the
spaceships flying around they're going
to have to be a specific problem because
it's going to be a two-hour movie it
can't be
big if you know what I mean it's gonna
have to be focused in some way
and it's going to have to be you know a
team with a problem blah yeah for for
just the reference is just you know very
fresh in the brain but
I feel like it it doesn't need to be the
Barbie movie at all but the Barbie movie
is very like large in scope and scale
while still very much following a
smaller narrative and I think it does
that it's not necessarily as good of a
movie as I want it to be but it is good
as well yada yada that's a whole
different conversation uh I I do think
it does very well with keeping a small
narrative and a bigger broader world
and that could be a good way of handling
that I guess I guess
um
as long as the right place has gone
forever yeah the replica is to death
by the end of SGU I was I was sick to
death of the replicated but it was like
oh there's an ancient replicators is
there as well oh okay so that whole
thing about it being a toy that just got
out of hand
are we forgetting that now
um anyway it's an inspiration
uh Andrew's asked questions do you think
it would be dull for a broader audience
dull it down
I don't think it'd be dull I think it'll
be an action-packed movie but the
question is will US Gators be satisfied
because that's the difficulty are they
going to give us enough that we feel
like it's a gay Stargate movie still
but make a film that non-gaters
understand
which is difficult because I feel like
stargaters or Gators in general are just
it's going to be hard to please us but
also super easy to please us at the same
time like just some Nostalgia would just
be like yes thank you great you know
make us feel good but I think
I don't know I just think the type of
people that like Stargate are not going
to be the type of people who will like
that
in the long term kind of like uh wearing
Star Wars stuff right now kind of like a
rise of Skywalker where a lot of people
came out of that movie like that was not
the Last Jedi I had a great time this is
fun like you know and then 20 minutes
later that was me I was like oh that was
that was a really good time and 20
minutes later I was at a deer lease and
my dad and I had to drive an hour back
and on that just right back we just
started picking the movie apart we were
like what the hell was that you know it
just it was brutally Frankenstein
together and you could kind of tell that
we don't want that to happen okay
I guess no no well it seems to me
they're putting a lot of work in and if
anything this the strikes are not a good
thing for anybody but if you're going to
look at for a slight Silver Lining it is
giving them longer to to plan this
um I should say actually by the way that
um apparently the decision was made
mid-june that they wouldn't be making an
announcement at San Diego Comic-Con they
said bye uh uh about the 10th or 12th of
June apparently that was decided
um they said they got to a point where
it was very clear the actors were going
to go on strike so they made the
decision then and that's when they
basically said they weren't going to be
really going sounding a Comic-Con at all
um so this is your mate and they just
sort of slowed everything down a little
bit but it's also given a chance to have
another thing
how how important do we think Amazon
so the question is does Amber going to
care about Gators
can I steal it from you real quick just
because like the the the most blatant
example of that they have to care and
they know they have to care they you
would have said this two years ago three
years ago even
it'd be a lot more iffy it'd be a lot
more open and in the air but after rings
of power and after they saw what they
did to Lord of the Rings and Tolkien
fans they know that they can't
disappoint Stargate fans they know that
for anybody RoboCop people too because
that RoboCop something that they could
easily just kind of toss back out there
that's something that hell yeah we we
like some cool sci-fi cool Shoot Em Up
stuff toss that back out there but they
know they can't screw it up so they've
taken their time I'm assuming that's
what they're doing with Legally Blonde
three too because that's another thing
that they could have just tossed out
let's not let's not we got to be careful
with actually Donna jinx it because then
you know that's the important Point
that's the projectable change in the
channel name to Legally Blonde three
trick of course because that's the same
thing
um for me I know that um there's quite a
large
um marketing um company that um actually
somebody that worked MGM that got sacked
and moved over there
um and they do marketing work for Amazon
and MGM and apparently the the term is
let's not bring of power this and it is
it is specifically known that that was a
thing that everyone was so negative
about it before it came out
um and there was so much stuff they they
real they are actively trying to avoid
that in future and if they do a hard
reboot
the fans are gonna go crazy
I mean when you alienate your cooked in
audience like already baked into the the
DNA of what the show is
and just you just alienate them from the
start what
you're shooting yourself in the foot the
definition of it making it a lot harder
to walk especially Sprint and I would
actually argue that Roland Emrick told
us this over a year ago he actually he
told us
in the lines now exactly what was
happening I didn't drop my microphone I
don't know what you're talking about
Mike
pretty good
um
that he basically said one that the
Amazon only care about the TV audience
he basically said if there's a movie
they've got to involve me because I'm
contracted which again now we realize
it's because they must have gone to him
and said we're thinking about doing a
movie and that's the only reason he was
even bringing it up
so I think they approached Roland
Limerick and said we're doing a movie
and he's going to be an executive
producer and a producer on this whatever
they end up doing
um but he's already said but I don't
want
to take the reins I don't want to leave
the because
it's going to be an sg1 movie it's going
to be an SGA movie it's the TV audience
that match to Amazon
I think that tells us if you read
between the lines that tells us
everything we need to know and from what
we know since sort of thing that tells
us everything for me
TV orders all that matters and they were
thinking about a movie even then which
is a few months before I started here in
the rumor that that they were they were
seriously thinking movie
well
I liked I I well I'm I like I said I'm I
am easy to please especially in the
Sci-Fi category
I do love me some b-roll and Emerick I
saw moonfall on IMAX and had him you
know I was at the interview so like the
premiere ish I guess uh did you put your
hand up and go what the what the [__]
was that and then you say and then he
sort of talking no no seriously what the
[__] is that just
the only good thing I got out of that
was wanting to watch Stargate so
um yeah I I just don't I just don't
think we we need to
um I I don't think this is a producer I
think would be fine I I don't mind him
being a producer at all and my I guess
you made me think of a question if
because you know just because you've
you've had some fun talks about it
if a Stargate uh Universe animated movie
does happen or anything of the sort
would he be
even if it's animation would he be an
executive producer in that field as well
or is it strictly live action no it's
only if it's a moving
um a cinematic movie is my understanding
that he has to be involved which is
again another hint yeah
well if they put the anime
the new TV movies they did it didn't
they and he doesn't have to be involved
yeah but they could put the animated
film in theaters as well huh
I don't think that's the plan I don't
want to say too much I've got a video
coming
but I don't think there'll be an SGU
cinematic movie now all right okay okay
um
I don't want to say too much about that
so I don't want to ruin the surprise and
I still want to work on the video a
little bit because I'm still not 100
certain about a few points but again
teasing you guys I know but yeah
um uh Andrew yeah um it's I'm expecting
my DVD to come anytime I think it's I
think it's the end of this week I think
it's all this down next week
um so yeah the B5 release date is done I
ordered mine a couple of weeks ago my
thinking is I will watch it and then I
will give it away to one of you guys
um so don't you don't have to buy it
just yet
real quick go on just because you
brought this up earlier how Babylon 5
just because it is a hard reboot but is
uh JMS doing it right is that right okay
okay uh
what would you think if Brad Wright
wanted hard reboot started
would it be okay then
it would get more credibility wouldn't
it a little bit it would be a lot harder
to argue with it and to be honest it
take it will take the wind out of all
the sales
say this director it got its own way say
he decided I want to do a hard reboot
and
Amazon oh okay then even though all the
evidence up till now is just that's not
gonna happen so please don't panic
um
to take the wind out of all of the
negative people sales is by getting Brad
right involved
that's true even if it were were to do
something like that drastic I guess for
lack of a better term
um
yeah I don't know there's just a thought
that came to mind I don't even know what
I'd think about that it's I am it would
it would look to be honest if they did a
hard reboot I'll be disappointed
I'll be annoyed
um but I'll still be thinking well at
least we can Stargate back and this
could be a new birth so we might look
back on it in a couple of years and go
what were we worried about that's
amazing
um we've still got the we've still got
sg1 and SG USGA that's still there we
can watch it whenever we like but now
we've got this new Stargate as well
which is even better you know that could
happen but
um but it could happen
um and um
so I would I wouldn't I wouldn't I would
try not to panic but
um it's not what we want
you know they they could do something
amazing but it's it's not
it's not what we want
so we'll see fun little exercise of
thought but um yeah
but yeah if they brought Brad right back
it would be hard to argue with it
wouldn't it I mean that's the thing for
anyone that goes on about how they don't
want a hard reboot of Babylon 5 is to
just go it's jms's show he wants to do
it shut up basically it's not it's not
up to you just shut up so just another
dumb bad thought just just to tap that
one real quick Brad Wright writes it and
Roland Emerick directs it exactly yeah
well no
rolling them next time was 10 years ago
yeah I'm sorry I do have to call it an
evening guys and we went through
everything we wanted to go through I
didn't want to give you two long cameras
and my throat is killing me and
um so that's basically it
um
movie 70 80 million dollars hard reboot
is possibly on the table at the very
least Amazon won't say no
um yet and
Amazon are making real strides towards
getting anything up to 40 to 50 sound
stages by next summer which is
astonishing if that if that happens
because I mean that is but this deal
with the hackerman group looks like it's
a very easy way of getting a lot of
sound stages very very quickly
um it's the main reason why the Hackman
group are building 90 new sound stages
and they're still going ahead with that
even though
um everything's happened in the last 12
months and they're still going ahead
with all this development money and
thing and it's mainly because
of giving this many sound stages to you
know Amazon so on all over the world as
well Island Canada and America they're
looking at more soundstages good
fantastic well I mean as worried as we
have been and you know rightfully so for
many many many reasons
we did just have the fourth largest box
office opening weekend of all time yep
things are still kicking
yeah I think that's astonishing I think
that's absolutely astonishing I think it
just shows that we have to readjust a
lot and and
two movies bouncing off of one another
like that
helps a lot I I don't know I don't know
it's really interesting to think about
talk about a good thought experiment
yeah yeah 100 right guys thank you so
much we've had over 100 people
um watching at times tonight which is
brilliant particularly for a video that
I decided to do five minutes before we
started
um and I'm sure we're going to come back
to this and discuss it again I'm sure
I'll try to get a few more details over
the next couple of weeks but really
we're in a holding pattern right now
anyway no no new decisions gonna be made
there might be some development work
over the next couple of months but
there's going to be nothing now until
the strikes surrounded we're not
expecting any official announcement
until the strikes are done
and then hopefully something will happen
very very quickly so guys thank you so
so much
um Everybody in the um comments you've
been amazing today thank you you've
really thrown out some amazingly very
interesting ideas as well as you always
do uh Harris thank you very much for
helping me just come and uh sort of
recapping it all together you know
yeah we should be seeing you tomorrow on
M cubed we might actually stream on both
channels again because that was quite
good we need to get you some [__]
subscribers so please go over and
subscribe to mq there is a link in the
description and I think it's on my um my
the YouTube channel as well I think if
you scroll down there's like connected
channels I think I think I think so I
think Matt did it so again that'll take
you straight there
thank you everybody we will see you soon
well we'll see you tomorrow and we'll
see you Sunday for the usual live of
course bye everybody
foreign
[Music]